Arthur I have some bad news for you this
is the last time we'll be meeting you
don't listen to you you just ask the
same questions every week how's your job
are you having any negative thoughts
all I have are negative thoughts
walking in congrats on the film I read
somewhere that Todd said it took him a
couple months of convincing to get you
to do this role and even then you didn't
give him a hard yes so what was it that
finally convinced you to take on this
role it's been our girl might my
girlfriend about it you're like you
always knew you were doing it um I said
I did because I remember really
struggling with the decision and she
said yeah you kept saying you weren't
sure but we knew from the moment that
you first talked about that you're gonna
do it so much sure what that moment was
where I was contractually obliged to to
make the film but I I mean I think I
always go through a long process with
deciding if I'm gonna make a movie or
not I guess it's just like wanting to be
sure or at least as close to sure as
possible that you want to take on the
experience but I know that from when I
first met Todd I really liked him and I
trusted him and I thought that he had a
unique way into this character and into
this world so it felt pretty confident
of that I think I just was probably
unsure of myself
interesting did any of that have to do
with the laughs maybe I know everyone's
probably asking you about the laughs no
nobody has oh no I'm I have to ask you
because watching it is a little
uncomfortable at times you know it kind
of feels like you're choking while doing
it
yet I love how it's used in the story to
kind of propel the story forward so was
that laughs easy or hard to come by and
how did you come to it um before I read
the script Todd showed me videos of
people that have this uncontrollable
laughing Fitz and one in particular who
it looked very painful as facial to get
read and he would he would choke and so
that was the inspiration that I really I
just tried to copy copy them
and you know taught it always it was it
was described in the script it's
something that was almost painful and so
I thought that was such a unique way of
approaching the Joker's laughs which is
so iconic and I think I'd always
imagined it as being just maniacal kind
of high-pitched yeah and and I think
that the way that Todd had approached it
was do this were realistic lens and and
kind of felt like it was it was
motivated by something and so it was
finding that but you know some days it
was easier than others yeah I can't
imagine you mentioned Joker's iconic
laugh and we've seen a lot of different
jokers right from the comic book and
from pop culture was there anything
specific that you took from Joker's
personality from comic books or pop
culture that you wanted to weave into
your version of the character no not one
thing mm-hmm what about the dancing I
know that you had a choreographer for
this step scene you watched a lot of
internet dancing videos which internet
dancing videos you know influenced
Arthur's moves there is and I'm scared
I'm gonna [ __ ] up his name I said his
name before an interview but I just kind
of mumbled it if I could get away with
it but now now I'm doing it so I want to
say ray Bolger but I'm afraid that it's
Roy Bolger and it's so stupid because I
mean I watched this video countless
times and I think it's the thing that
influenced my movement the most and it's
a song and a dance that he did called
the old soft shoe this one's made of but
it's not it's real and I think that
probably I think that affected affected
me the most Wow
I got to look that up the old soft shoe
it's not really me I'm gonna be so sad
if I go home
there is it no it's filly made up
something that I have to say something
to kind of pass the time
oh so there wasn't a specific dance
video on the Internet
well there was one there was a there's a
fella named Roy Bolger and a song called
the old song okay now that you by the
way that is real okay I'm happy to know
that don't look because I'm ended up but
I didn't know if I even really existed
but I do
so Tod one of the interesting things
about this film is that we actually get
to learn the origin of jokers laughs so
I'd love to know the inspiration behind
that and how you came to it I think the
fun thing about writing this movie was
basically figuring out how to run
everything that we know of Joker through
his realistic a lens as possible if that
makes sense so for example why is his
skin white and his hair green what you
know how does that come to be in the
real world why does he have this laughs
in the real world so we did a little bit
of research on things like spontaneous
laughter and found that there's this
actual affliction and it's not meant to
be funny in the movie and it's not but
it is a real thing so and that was a
challenging thing for Joaquin de to find
that laughs because you know you read
the script and it says Arthur starts
laughing you know it's pain there's pain
in his eyes he can't stop and buy blood
that you read that you okay but to act
that is a very very difficult thing and
it was very intimidating for what came
he talked a lot about the laughs because
you've seen the movie comes up a lot and
but it was fun yeah him and I talked
about it I can't imagine how hard that
was right on top of losing all that
weight I mean Joaquin loses over 50
pounds you know but I read somewhere
Todd that he actually thought that the
character should gain weight so I wanted
to know from you what is the story
behind that and how did you guys land on
a weightless well I mean I think he
wanted the character to gain weight
because I think he just didn't want to
deal with the struggle of losing you
know that much weight but so he came to
me and he was like you know what about
the opposite what if we just play him
like doughy and heavy and not gain a
little weight and I said no I think it's
really important that Arthur kind of
looks and feels like a wolf like
something like malnourished and hungry
you know like and we had conversations
and I won that one and he had to go lose
52 pounds although I didn't expect him
to lose that much in fairness he just
went with it oh really so it was more
than what you well I mean we just wanted
him to be really who we didn't put a
number on it I just said just be really
young skinny and
he did I want to ask you about Scorsese
because there are a lot of parts of this
film that feel like they're influenced
by the king of comedies and you talked
to Martin beforehand did you get any
advice from him the movie it was okay
comedy is definitely a reference in the
movie and an inspiration for sure and
it's not only king of comedy to be fair
it's a total it's really a time period
of movies I'm way older than you that I
grew up watching which is really that
mid 70s to the early 80s kind of these
great character studies Sidney Lumet
films Martin Scorsese movies for sure
yeah so oh and I did actually send the
script to Martin Scorsese which was a
trip in and of itself and he read and we
had a nice great phone call about it and
I was about the extent of it but it was
it was amazing for me
that's incredible has he seen the film
he hasn't seen it yet no he's been
knee-deep on irishman and which I can't
wait to see and um yeah I know he hasn't
seen it yet but I want him to Wow that
is iconic yeah now that you have Joker
under your belt Todd is there another
comic book character that you'd maybe
want to do a character study oh no you
know it's not like I was ever dying to
do comic book movies honestly I just I I
saw it as a really um kind of fun
sandbox to go into and try something
really different with which is what we
did with Joker it's not that now I want
to make other comic book movies and
again not that I wouldn't but there's
not something where I'm like oh now we
should do this same sort of formula and
do it too that I like that this movie
hopefully will will stand on its own and
people will I hopefully love it or and
you know I'm sure not everybody will
it's not for everyone but no I haven't
really thought about other comic book
characters
you